celebration music yes celebration time
for the boys the chair is yours yeah I
have to uh I have to do a couple of them
this is uh obviously first
yeah
first interview your own chart is first
let's go let's Crank that up
yeah now we can just crank it in the
winner of music
[Music]
yes
oh that was uh
that was very smooth Armageddon yeah I
mean I thought I just uh
I thought I'd just get a position where
I can't be attacked so that was my main
so I thought we'd get there and then I'd
just wait for him to try and do
something and yeah immediately as I did
that the C4 was a turning point yeah
like when you go to C6 you're just still
and DC is gonna make a loop Saturday
yeah but the point is like these
positions are better for white but it's
not so easy like once you start doing
stuff then you often it's often
backpacks yeah
uh how it lives forever there we go so
uh yeah I mean this is all very logical
uh
faster no B4 is fine
you're still waiting I'm still waiting
yeah okay so D5 Bishop D2 still waiting
you felt you should got to do something
here uh no I don't actually have to play
D5 I I but okay I felt like it's like
King AJ I could also go King h8 and he
kind of 3D do much at all but yeah yeah
difa was maybe you know necessary but
still Bishop D2 King h8 like not much is
uh not much is happening but yeah I mean
takes a name privacy
yeah there's never some Queen V3 yeah
you always are like broken yeah yeah
yeah then it's
yeah after this
so it's big uh big uh
yeah
we talked 92 was nice afterwards he
didn't even more Stylo like he drew all
these kids yeah
sorry my 92 92 was nice it was a nice
combo yeah oh yeah yeah but uh not too
difficult it has a rook attitude that
was an armor get them exactly yeah
exactly
and uh well let me see like later
uh yeah here I thought I should go like
okay
[Music]
could you make sure to bring the mic
down it's connected just bring it to
your face